this is probably one of the best
chapters of hunter hunter that I've ever
read it's also easily one of the hardest
and it only gets worse because this is a
very sinking kind of chapter there's a
lot of information and implications here
that don't really hit you straight away
but when they do it hits hard I feel
like I now have a close to complete
understanding of how the Phantom troop
came to be what they are today and it
has very little to do with what was
actually said in the chapter and a hell
of a lot more with what was implied we
now legitimately have the answers as to
how they were corrupted as well as how
many of them developed their net
abilities because a shocking amount of
troop members with this context in mind
have powers directly correlated to
sarasa's death it's all very tragically
beautiful and stupidly amazing writing
from tagashi and let's get into it first
up I want to give all of the props in
the world tagashi's assistance for 397
because they were the ones to put in the
work to create the atmosphere of the
forest where our trooplings found
sarasa's remains tagashi unfortunately
just isn't physically capable of
producing that level of detail so the
assistants have seriously pulled through
here they took the scene and gave a
Shona manga a very scene and atmosphere
the hyper realistic Forest is integral
in making this moment land because it
confronts the Phantom troop with nothing
except the cold hard reality of what
this world actually is because it hides
nothing this isn't just a fun fantasy
world anymore everything in this world
is now on full display and I really
appreciate the realistic atmosphere
being used to give our troop a very
harsh introduction to reality something
I want to note though is that crolo
definitely knew sarasa was dead before
they started searching for her because
he is just far too smart for his own
good he did the maths he understood
exactly what had happened to make sarasa
not show up to the performance and he
started crying on stage due to the
obvious conclusion that moment of him
crying on stage it hurt like it really
hurt because it tells the whole story
without any story needing to be told and
I completely understand that feeling of
like Dread you know the whole knowing
that something isn't okay but still
trying to grasp on to any potential of
Hope regardless in retrospect I also
find it incredibly morbid that the first
exciting image that tagashi posted on
Twitter turned out to be the tree that
held sarasa's remains Togashi you are an
absolute dick wizard meaning the
internet went insane with hype due to
that image of the tree and to know that
it was all leading to this makes me feel
really really kind of stained because I
retweeted that damn tree and now just ah
what have I done the message
accompanying sarasa's body is something
that I don't think will ever be revealed
to us it's written in a gibberish
language that I don't think is meant to
be understood at least not by the
readers however if I had to guess it
would be a detailed description of
everything The Killers did to sarasa at
the moment I can't think of any other
reason why crawler would refuse to tell
everyone else what it says and since the
killers are just so proud of their work
I think it does make sense they would
want the details as well known as
possible and this this is one of those
sinking moments because it's not until
later in the chapter when you see all of
the evidence collected in the plastic
bags which includes at least seven
different kinds of knives all stained
with sarasa's blood like this is
legitimately sickening The Killers left
the murder implements behind on purpose
they did so so that whoever found the
body knew in excruciating detail exactly
what happened who it happened to and
exactly how it happened it was probably
one of the worst possible ways to die
imaginable back to the note though as
soon as I saw it I immediately thought
of the note that the troop left at the
site of the curta massacre which again
is quite a sickening thought a lot of
this chapter is about sickening thoughts
but the troop definitely used this
experience with sarasa and adopted a lot
of the features of this event for their
own future use which is one step towards
understanding the modern Phantom Troupe
because crolo's plan ends up being to
turn meteor City into a safe haven for
the world's worst criminals to entice
sarasa's Killers into revealing
themselves in a metaphorical sense
crawler was creating a spider web for
them to get stuck in and in this case
that's particularly appropriate taking
into account the internet web that was
developing and I just want to dwell on
this for a second because the impact of
this did not hit me at first but when it
did I felt physically ill essentially
what crawler was proposing is the
creation of a cinema where the killers
would be enticed to showcase the murder
of Sarasota that they filmed kind of
like a really twisted version of what
the kids were doing with the cleanup
Ranger episodes whether that's a
physical or a digital cinema I don't
know but it also doesn't really matter
because here's the key implication in
that quest to find sarasa's Killers the
Phantom troop would have had to watch
countless snuff films because this would
have attracted the entire underworld in
search of this one tape the Phantom
troop would have had to go through
hundreds perhaps even thousands of
videos of real people being murdered
which I think very satisfactorily
explains how they became so desensitized
to murder and death and in some cases
probably even learned from the tapes
like how fatan became such an expert in
torture and then you think back to stuff
like York New City when gon asked Rollo
hey how can you just kill people who
have nothing to do with you and crolo
doesn't really give an answer in fact he
says that he struggles to convey it
verbally because it has never been
conveyed to him or by him verbally it
all just developed due to this repeated
exposure to murder via these videotapes
in increasingly brutal and creative ways
to the point where killing itself has
become practically Dane I do think we
still have at least one more step before
we understand the motive of the curta
massacre currently all I can think of is
that their killing was essential to
build the reputation of meteor city as a
criminal Haven where anything goes
because hey it's pretty difficult to
commit a crime larger than genocide plus
there's also the whole aspect of body
part collecting which probably does have
a bit of a crossover with the um I guess
let's call it the film industry and I
would personally find that answer
satisfying because it doesn't vindicate
or even attempt to vindicate their
actions Sheila is a very interesting
aspect of this chapter because she is
shown departing the group both
physically and metaphorically which
gives us two options for her either
she's feeling very guilty because she
was somehow involved in this dark
industry or Sheila has become
disillusioned by her friends who all
seem to be very quick to just throw
their lives away to become villains and
remembering that Sheila's dream is to
become a hunter she may have been the
only real person to escape this
friendship group with any real hope
remaining which then resulted in her
unintentionally saving karapika but that
in turn ended up killing Sheila's
friends over again and so we've got some
very Shakespearean style tragedy
Happening Here an unexpected highlight
of the chapter was further development
of the crolo over again relationship
this is something I definitely did not
expect but when UVA refused leadership
of the troop and instead nominated
crawler that absolutely generated some
feels a very mixed mess of feelings that
is because it is quite touching these
two have had their moment of
understanding but also knowing what it
leads to just completely twists and
subverts the sweet nature of it I tell
you what though this makes crolo's
Requiem for over again so so so much
sadder in retrospect I mean when I was
going through York new city for the
first time I saw that as an act of pure
respect for his Fallen comrade like the
Phantom troops equivalent of a funeral
but now I almost see it as pure mourning
like a raw emotional release of grief in
this case taken out in extremely violent
ways but still I suppose my question at
this point is whether or not the troop
have actually found sarasa's Killers yet
because if not I imagine that this would
need to tie into the succession more
events however they very much could have
dealt with sarasa's Killers years and
years and years ago because here's the
thing chrolo and cropicus stories are
now basically the same a Vengeance Quest
where both Geniuses resolve to become a
villain for the sake of the fallen and I
can see a situation where crolo and the
troop did find sarasa's Killers then
they viciously kill murdered them and
acted you know the Vengeance but then
ended up in the exact same spot that
karapika did after killing uvgin that
sense of emptiness and a kind of sadness
that achieving Revenge did absolutely
nothing but then I also thought back to
York New Again specifically the moment
where parkinoda asked gone in kilua why
they won't run away and they answer that
it's because they're krapika's friends
and they don't want him to become a
murderer AKA they don't want him to walk
down the same path that crolo and the
troop did now gone obviously didn't know
that but paku noticed saw the
similarities and that's why she was
thankful because karapika unlike them
had friends that were willing to stop
them doing what they did after Sarasota
I mean sort of krapika did still kill
uvgin but hence why Finks and feitan
also treated gone and killua much more
empathetically at the auction because
parkunoda included that memory to give
them which is particularly striking
because gone and kilowatt are obviously
children and pretty much smack bang on
the same age as most of the troop were
when sarasa died these last few chapters
have recontextualized so much of the
series and after we finished here I
desperately want to reread all of York
new city with this new context in mind
speaking of parkinot's powers though
she's one of the troop members whose
abilities make a tragic degree of sense
hakunoda can read memories and I imagine
that that was designed so that she could
ultimately read and confirm exactly who
it was that killed sarasu and she's
definitely not the only one impacted by
this Marchi is another tragic example
her string Powers were formed out of a
desire to make sure that nobody ended up
like sarasa chopped into pieces and such
and now machi's whole thing is about
putting people back together so Machi
very much took after the ninen bomber
whose name is renko and looks really
cool actually she seems a bit more
overly designed than your usual tagashi
character and I'm hoping that means that
we'll see more of her in the future also
Machi could just naturally see Aura I
mean obviously not naturally it would
have had to be awakened somehow but
that's kind of crazy because even after
Awakening you would generally need to
use guillot to actually see raura Machi
did not unless she was unconsciously
using gear in which case she is an
absolute genius Machi is a very special
nen user and she's also being quite
isolated in this flashback generally
operating counter to everyone else so
getting her in little slivers of
individual Focus very much like how
she's currently on her own now aboard
the Blackwell one back to abilities
though crolo skill Hunter is very much
because he prioritizes a wide breadth of
information and tools to use for his
plan but even feitan's pain Packer could
be a direct result of sarasa that innate
desire to inflict as much damage as was
done to her onto sarasa's Killers
because that's basically what pain
Packer does it takes every bit of damage
that you've done and makes you pay for
it with interest but you know the one
key question that we still have an
answer in this flashback is who was the
original number eight and number four
members of the truth because we now know
that whoever they were they definitely
weren't part of the founding members so
those two must have been collected
afterwards and if this troop flashback
does continue I would love to see it
cover who those two members were as well
as briefly touch on the recruitment
origin of members like banolanov shizuku
and kotope because they feel like as
soon as we reach that point then the
troop storyline is ready to be wrapped
up in a neat little package meaning that
we can prepare for most if not all of
them today but also thinking back on it
during the best time of crolo's life
without initial cleanup ranges episode
he was most animated and arguably best
at playing the villain so it's no
surprise that he's done such a great job
of that as an adult as well and also not
to be neglected there is a much grander
irony to the situation because as a
result of crolo setting up his spiderweb
of meteor city as a Nexus of human evil
that is exactly what has attracted gyro
there our living incarnation of evil and
with all of the troop currently out of
the picture there is nothing whatsoever
stopping jira from using the evil that
crolo has built and overseen as the
first step in the ultimate destruction
of humanity